PoPour le panel entre trouve de
chchef de bureau.
MaMadeleine Blais-Morin à Ottaw,
etet Sébastien Bovet.
Ce qui a marqué le la journée,
c'c'est les excuses du Pape et s
dédélégations qui ont passé la
sesemaine au Vatican.
CeCes excuses étaient dans les
rerecommandations de ces comités
dede réconciliation.
- - On avait entendu les
tétémoignages des dizaines,
cecentaines, probablement des
mimilliers victime des pensionns
auautochtones, ils étaient arris
avavec une des 94 recommandatio,
ilil demandait des excuses du
papape.
DeDes excuses du pape ici, au
CaCanada.
LaLa position n'avait pas choisi
cecette recommandation au hasar,
elelle savait que c'était
imimportant pour les victimes ds
nanations autochtones.
PoPour qu'on reconnaissait
ofofficiellement par la bouche u
SaSaint-Père, les horreurs qui t
étété commises dans ses
pepensionnats.
LeLes mots qui ont été prononcés
ététaient très peu importants, t
onon attend qu'elle soit de
nonouveau prononcé au Canada.
- - Le Justin Trudeau également?
- - Il dit lui aussi que c'est n
prpremier pas, la réconciliatio,
c'c'est un chemin qui va être
lolong.
C'C'est le genre de discours que
JuJustin Trudeau prononce souvet
lolorsque l'on parle de la
réréconciliation avec les peupls
auautochtones.
C'C'est quand même une bonne
nonouvelle pour Justin Trudeau
paparce que lorsqu'il a prie le
popouvoir en 2015 il avait acceé
totoutes les recommandations, ls
9494 en disant qu'on va travailr
àà ce qu'elles soient toutes
mimises en oeuvre même s'il y ea
plplusieurs qui n'était pas de n
reressort.
LeLes excuses du pape évidemment
cece n'était pas lui qui pouvait
leles prononcer.
MaMais il y en avait d'autres qi
vevenaient des provinces, on
paparlait du système de justice,
dede santé, de l'éducation.
ElElles ne sont pas toutes mises
enen oeuvre jusqu'à maintenant.
C'C'est une étape, mais une étae
d'd'un long chemin vers la
réréconciliation.
- - Parlant celle de Québec, es-
cece qu'il y a eu des réactions
susur la chaîne provinciale?
- - On n'avait pas accès aux él,
mamais sur les réseaux sociaux,
papas de réaction.
CÇa ne veut pas dire que les ges
icici ne salue pas la décision u
papape de transmettre ces exexc.
C'C'est comme si on avait
l'l'impression que le processus
s's'est accéléré depuis qu'on a
dédécouvert les sépultures dans
leles pensionnats, il y avait ue
prpression pour que l'église
rereconnaissait ces corps et que
leles excuses soient faites
auaujourd'hui.
AvAvec cette étape qui est
frfranchie.
- - Pas de réaction en tant que
tetel, ça venait de Manon Massé
ququi reprochait à Cackett de ne
papas retenir ses promesses au
PrPremières Nations.
ReRegardant le tweet ici.
EnEn fait, elle dit qu'il n'a ps
rerespecté son engagement
d'd'inscrire ce principe de
sésécurité culturelle à
l'l'intérieur de la loi. Je
vovoulais vérifier avec vous ce
mamatin, est-ce qu'on va y
rerenoncer.
- - Il a renoncé pour cette
sesession n parlementaire, jusqx
élélections.
SiSi jamais cette notion de
sésécurisation culturelle est
inincorporée à la loi sur la
sasanté, ce sera seulement dans
leles prochains mois.
AuAu cours de la prochaine année
pepeut-être, ou des deux
prprochaines années.
CÇa permet de faire le pont... e
ququi s'est passé ici à
l'l'Assemblée nationale, avec ds
exexcuses du pape : il y a des
ététapes sont franchies, mais ça
nene règle pas tout.
IlIl est essentiellement de dire
quque dans le réseau de la sant,
ququand des gens qui donnent des
sosoins font affaire avec des
auautochtones, il y a une réalié
paparticulière dont il faut être
coconscient il y a des
coconversations particulières.
IlIl faut déterminer des servics
dedes soins qui sont sécurisant
popour les autochtones à travers
lele réseau de la santé.
LeLe ministre Lafrenière s'est
enengagé à l'inclure dans la loi
susur la santé, or il ne sera ps
cacapable de le faire.
OnOn a beau se franchir des
ététapes, avoir des engagements
popour changer les choses, dansa
réréalité ce n'est pas toujours
fafacile de provoquer ce
chchangement et de sécuriser ce
chchoix.
- - On a signé d'autres points,
elelle a repris des propos qui
viviennent des Premières Nations
cecette semaine.
DeDe refuser les langues
auautochtones dans la loi.
LaLa décision du ministre,... ça
cocommence à s'additionner, c'et
unun drôle de contexte parce qun
esest dans la semaine où le pape
ofoffre ses excuses.
- - Il y a la réalité de la
foformation des travailleurs
enensanglantés.
NoNous sommes le 1er avril, il a
3030 % des travailleurs qui ont
étété formés.
EÉvidemment il y a eu la
papandémie, des fois ça va pas
vivite, mais c'est comme si la
momort de Joyce Echaquan était n
élélectrochoc.
OnOn parle des sépultures, des
pepensionnats autochtones, c'est
unun électrochoc au Canada, mais
ilil faut faire des suivis et
paparfois les suivis n'aboutisse
papas.
PaPas dans le calendrier qu'on
esespérait.
- - Quand on parle de
rerecommandations, sur la scène
féfédérale, sur la scène
prprovinciale, c'est la suite ds
enenquêtes qu'on connaît aussi.
IlIl y a cette autre grosse éta,
cecette visite du pape qui est
trtrès attendu.
OnOn entendu le témoignage tant,
popour eux c'est très importanat
ququ'elles parviennent sur le
teterritoire pour présenter ses
exexcuses.
LeLe chef que j'ai eu mon entree
j'j'espère qu'il n'ira pas dans
l'l'Ouest.
MaMais qu'il viendra aussi du cé
dede Québec.
MaMadeleine, qu'est-ce que ça vt
didire la visite d'un pape poure
féfédéral, pour le gouvernement?
- - Ça veut dire pas mal
d'd'organisation, mais... commee
lele disais tout à l'heure, ce
seserait une bonne nouvelle pour
lele gouvernement canadien.
SaSa partie près, ça
cocontribueraient, les sévices t
étété commis ici, on attend le
papape ici.
LaLa recommandation disait que e
papape vienne au Canada présentr
seses excuses.
J'J'aimerais bien qu'il vienne u
QuQuébec aussi, il y a eu des
exexpériences individuelles un u
papartout au pays.
EÉvidemment, il y a eu un tort
cocollectif, mais il y a eu ausi
plplusieurs compétiteurs
inindividuels qui ont été causés
etet qui ont eu des répercussios
mumulti générationnelle.
C'C'est normal que les Premières
NaNations qui ont passé après ce
prprocessus pénible des
pepensionnats autochtones, elle
mémérite ses personnes-là des
exexcuses dans leur coin de pay.
OnOn va voir comment ça va
s's'articuler, on n'a pas de da,
onon n'a pas de logistique, on a
papas de programme officiel, mas
dede toute façon je pense que sl
vivient au Canada, en prononçant
dedes excuses, je pense que ce
seserait une grande étape.
DeDemain on n'a pas de date mais
onon sait qu'il a une préférence
popour l'été.
- - Je dirais que tout ça a pasé
l'l'atmosphère.
D'D'après on va parler de la
COCOVID, il y a une sorte de
sususpension Québec, Sébastien,
susur le masque.
EsEst-ce que c'est lundi qu'on
dedevrait avoir leur juste?
- - Le directeur de la santé
pupublique votre remettra
rerecommandation lundi.
IlIl y a la cellule de crise de
totous les lundis à 18 heures 3.
LeLe gouvernement est publiquemt
momoins actif pour gérer la COVD
: : ça ne veut pas dire qu'en
cocoulisse ne l'est pas.
LeLe Docteur Boileau va
trtransmettre à recommandations
popour arrêter le port du masque
lele 15 avril ou le maintenir un
pepeu plus.
IlIl y a énormément de pression
susur lui, pour maintenir le
mamasque.
LaLa pression vient du milieu
scscientifique, les gens disent:
gagardant le masque un peu, c'et
unune bonne barrière.
MaMardi, si le masque a été levé
1010 jours plus tard, le 15 avr,
unune annonce soit lundi ou mar.
- - Il y a le masque dans les
lilieux publics, mais il y a aui
lala question des écoles.
7575 % de hausse et d'absence
d'd'élèves et d'enseignants deps
unune semaine au Québec.
CÇa met les égales dans des
sisituations délicates.
OnOn peut toujours avoir un
enenseignant, on ne peut pas
obobliger.
- - Il y a peut-être un signal i
dodoit venir de l'absenter
pupublique.
LeLe signal doit peut-être êtree
l'l'enlever, mais on vous le
rerecommande fortement.
OnOn le mettait un mois de plus,
enen ce moment pays, à ma
coconnaissance, il n'y a qu'une
seseule l'autre province qui
mamaintient le port du masque.
ToTous les autres provinces ont
sususpendu le port du masque.
IlIl y a aussi ça qui joue dans
l'l'approche de la population.
- - Tout le monde dit oui mais
popourquoi pas lui, pourquoi
jujustement.
IlIl y a un peu cet effet.
CeCe qu'on a comprit Madeleine,n
vava terminer là-dessus, la sané
pupublic fédéral dit que la 16e
vavague ne rend pas de la même
fafaçon dans les différentes
prprovinces.
- - C'est pour cela que la santé
pupublique fédérale ne parle pas
dede sixième vague à l'échelle
nanationale.
ElElle ne disait pas que le Quéc
avavait tort de parler de sixièe
vavague.
MaMais c'est difficile d'avoir e
vavague qui se répercute de la
mmême façon partout.
OnOn a choisi d'utiliser d'autrs
momots, mais le message centrale
lala santé publique fédérale
c'c'était de dire que le virus t
enencore ici pour un bout de
tetemps, il faut falloir faire
atattention.
- - Message de prudence.
LeLe même qu'en entendant toutes
leles provinces, même si ce n'et
papas obligatoire, prenez pas de
ririsque pour rien.
- - Gérer vous.